Німеччина – парламентська демократія,
а зал засідань Бундестагу під скляним дахом –
її центр.
Наступні роки тут керуватиме він – Вольфґанґ Шойбле.
На першому ж засіданні нового німецього парламенту
його обрали головою Бундестагу.
Досі Шойбле очолював міністерство фінансів ФРН
і провадив політику жорсткої фінансової дисципліни
не тільки в Німеччині, але й на рівні Євросоюзу.
Нині у нього - не менші виклики:
вперше в історії повоєнної Німеччини
парламент країни пройшли праві популісти
з партії "Альтернатива для Німеччини", що на думку ЗМІ
неминуче означає скандали та сварки
в сесійній залі.
Повноважень, щоб навести лад, Шойбле вистачить.
За Конституцією, голова Бундестагу –
друга особа в ієрархії влади ФРН
після президента республіки,
що показує важливість парламенту в житті країни.
Власне, як і те, що за Конституцією,
парламент контролює також і німецький уряд,
армію та спецслужби. Саме президент Бундестагу
приймає присягу у президента країни,
канцлера та федеральних міністрів.
За традицією німецький парламент очолює представник партії,
яка набрала найбільше голосів на виборах.
Кожна з франкцій отримує посаду заступника голови Бундестагу.
Постійні парламентські комітети пропорційно представлятимуть
як правлячі, так і опозиційні партії.
А тимчасові слідчі комісії, на відміну від України,
депутати мають право створювати
усього чвертю голосів парламенту.
Чим німецька опозиція часто і користується.
Головне щоденне завдання голови Бундестагу –
керувати засіданнями.
На відміну від Росії, України чи Японії,
у німецькому парламенті ніхто не б’ється
та не блокує трибуну.
За потреби спікер може позбавити депутата слова
або навіть на місяць видалити з зали засідань.
Проте було б помилкою говорити,
що робота голови німецького парламенту
виключно процедурна. Попередній голова Бундестагу
Норберт Ламмерт не раз виступав
з гострими політчиними заявами. Так, після анексії Криму
він відмовився їхати з візитом в Москву,
не дозволяв депутатам Бундестагу відвідувати Крим,
а нещодавно знову заявив про підтримку
режисера Олега Сенцова.
А от у сесійній залі спікер парламенту
зобов’язаний зберігати нейтралітет -
хоча він і представляє найбільшу політичну партію.
Опозиція суворо стежить за тим,
щоб спікер не ухвалював рішення на користь своєї партії,
а усі фракції отримували рівні права.
75-річний Вольфґанґ Шойбле усе це чудово знає.
За збігом обставин він  -
ще й найдосвідченіший член парламенту,
який майже 45 років пропрацював в Бундестазі.